and our shoutout tonight goes to the
reporters at the Asbury Park Press in
New Jersey a small newspaper there's
some very big accomplishments a police
chase in New Jersey had led to this
fiery scene the car in flames was not
part of it but was instead driven off
the road by the vehicle being chased as
the innocent driver his clothing in
flames runs from his car for help police
arrived and instead of helping him some
of the officers begin to kick him and
then drag him away the incident was one
of dozens discovered by reporters for
the Asbury Park New Jersey press
uncovering what was a 60 million dollar
secret involving out-of-court
settlements that hid police misconduct
these settlement agreements that we were
reporting on mandate that both parties
remain silent you know if they were to
be asked about the issue they're just
going to quietly go their ways and the
taxpayers end up footing the bill on
this largely without knowing about it
Andrew Ford was the lead reporter of a 5
reporter team at the Asbury Park Press
in New Jersey which produced a 19 part
series called protecting the shield a
winner this year of an American Bar
Association silver gavel award
protecting the shield was made necessary
because of the shocking incidents that
we were covering off of the cops and
breaking news beat perhaps the most
striking is a Neptune Police Sergeant
who fatally shot his ex-wife in public
after a car chase in front of their
seven-year-old daughter
I ended up securing an exclusive
interview with him and detailed the
numerous warning signs that authorities
had before that killing actual actually
magic men children women who I was
married to for 20 years this was an
absolute team effort a number of
reporters photographers editors in the
room were involved in putting this huge
production together it took us something
like two years to get all this done so
this was a sweeping and comprehensive
look at police accountability and
problems in New Jersey it all how many
departments did you essentially pull
records owned we filed more than once
requests with every department in the
state that's a total of something like
468 municipal police departments the
reporting found more than 200 New Jersey
citizens were victims of what the paper
called
rogue cops including one man unarmed who
died in police custody
his final agonizing moments caught on
tape
[Music]
[Music]
his family sued and settled for $350,000
a fact the New Jersey town was not happy
to see published I think the town passed
a resolution condemning the the the
thrust of our reporting but not finding
any errors in the stories that we wrote
they actually passed a resolution
denouncing you yes the township passed a
resolution denouncing us but important
to note found no error in the story that
we wrote about what happened in their
town
but the series had huge impact including
from the story of an officer killed
off-duty in a car crash I found out that
he was drunk and on drugs at the time
found out that his department didn't
have a policy for random drug testing so
we requested drug testing policies from
every department in the state found that
more than 100 departments did not have a
policy for random drug tests and police
officers this sounds like the kind of
thing that any good local investigative
team could do anywhere in the country
that's absolutely right and you don't
have to be an investigative reporter to
do this kind of work investigative
journalism is alive and well in New
Jersey at the Asbury Park Press and at
the other papers in the USA Today
Network we're all working together out
here and we've continued to have
follow-up stories so stick with us and
we'll keep it going so to Andrew Ford
and his colleagues in this dynamic
editor Paul Dunn pro-c a big shout out
for letting its readers and New Jersey
taxpayers in on the 60 million dollar
hush money secret that's our program for
this week we hope to see you back here
again next week
you